[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock and you are very welcome to our
new look breakfast show a packed program
for you this morning we're speaking to
the housing secretary michael gove about
covid and cladding the world health
organization will give us their latest
assessment of omicron and the ukrainian
ambassador to the uk will be here in the
studio to discuss tensions with russia
it's monday the 10th of january
game set and match the world number one
tennis star novak djokovic wins his
appeal against a decision to refuse him
a visa ahead of the australian open
i'm live outside the immigration
detention hotel in melbourne where the
player has spent the last five days but
will now be allowed to leave
tragedy beyond measure at least 19
people including nine children killed in
a fire in a new york apartment block
that started in a malfunctioning heater
lines of attack we report from inside
kazakhstan as russian troops make their
mark at the airport
there has been a very heavy-handed
crackdown after these protests more than
6 000 protesters arrested and a number
of people killed keeps climbing and the
shoot to kill order remains in place
also
i'm live in kiev as ukraine braces for
the possibility of a further russian
invasion today u.s and russian officials
meet in geneva to discuss a crisis
that's seen a large buildup of russian
troops on ukraine's border
and i'm live at grenfell as a new
government plan to target developers
over dangerous cladding is revealed but
does that go far enough
more than 60 years ago marilyn monroe
won a golden globe last night there was
no red carpet no celebrities and no host
after a barrage of criticism we'll ask
is it the end of the road for the
ceremony
also this morning on the new lock
programme for you hoping to head off on
holiday i'm wondering what the current
restrictions are we'll have the latest
advice at half past nine this morning
plus we'll tell you how the common cold
may help protect you from covid
and after more than a million people
signed a petition calling for sotoni
blair to have his knighthood removed
we'll speak to his former director of
political operations as well as a father
whose son was killed in iraq to get
their take
[Music]
hello everybody a very good morning team
we start with the breaking news in the
last half an hour the world number one
tennis player novak djokovic has won his
appeal against a decision to refuse him
a visa to enter australia djokovic had
been held in an immigration detention
center after australia border
authorities did not approve his medical
exemption for not having a vaccine let's
talk about it in more detail nicole
johnston joining us from melbourne she's
outside the hotel where djokovic was
being held hello to you what happens now
nicole
well it's been an extraordinary day here
in court the real question as you said
is what comes next
we know that the federal government has
had its uh quashing
has had it it's been quashed the fact
that they tried to cancel his visa but
it's not quite over yet and that's
because it can now go back to the
federal government the immigration
minister and the department of home
affairs to decide whether or not they
will reinstate his visa they have given
some signs and indications uh over the
last couple of days that they will look
into that that they could personally
intervene and decide not to give him a
visa to enter the country
for now though uh the ruling has been in
his favor he'll be released from
detention he'll get his passport back
his personal effects and it's good news
on that front for the novak djokovic
team
but i'm sure that they'll be looking at
all of their legal options waiting to
find out what the next move will be from
the federal government essentially the
court found that there was a failure in
duel in due process that it wasn't fair
so from now we wait to hear from the
federal government
okay uh nicole thanks very much indeed
for the update thank you
now by the secretary of state for
housing communities and local government
michael gov happy new year to meet mr
gove lots to talk to you about should we
just start with that should we would we
allow novak djokovic to uh take part at
wimbledon if he wasn't vaccinated
sorry kay you were asking about novak
djokovic and wimbledon um well again
there's a as we've just heard there's a
a complex process going on in australia
we have to respect the integrity of that
process
and wimbledon is some months away the
thing i would say to anyone is that it
is good to get vaccinated it is good for
you it is good for others good for
society um but with his specific case of
mr djokovic well i'll leave it to the
australian authorities to decide that
for the moment um and as i say uh there
are plenty of uh sporting highlights
before we reach wimbledon bit of swerve
on that backhand are we ready to live
with covid here in the uk
i think we are getting ready to live
with covet absolutely um i think that uh
what's been striking is the success of
the booster campaign um
while there are with novak djokovic one
or two high-profile figures who uh uh
themselves haven't been vaccinated the
overwhelming good sense of the british
people has meant that um uh millions of
us um have been vaccinated have had our
booster and as a result we've been
playing our part in making sure that we
relieve the pressure on the nhs and make
sure that care is there for those who
need it
and we're ready to cut the isolation
period from seven to five days
sorry k i just missed that because i'm
afraid that i think i had your producer
in my ear rather than you i'm so sorry
oh i'm sorry about that i'm just asking
as a result are we saying that we are
ready to cut the isolation period from
seven days to five days
well we always keep these things under
review um and the most important thing i
think is to ensure that we are
we are in a position to uh protect uh
the nhs and to protect public services
so we at the moment are in a position
where we've reduced the uh uh isolation
period as you know from ten to seven
days we'll keep that under review um but
it will be the health secretary and the
prime minister who will make any
announcement in due course not me
it does sound as though the cabinet is
open to it though
well we always keep things um under
review because we're always guided by
the facts by the science and by uh
changing circumstances so
i think it's striking to note that in
the united kingdom overall particularly
in england we have one of the most um uh
open regimes one of the uh uh
essentially uh one of the
most liberal approaches of any country
in europe but we also need to balance
that with a determination to ensure that
we are not overwhelming the nhs and your
question gives me an opportunity just to
say thank you to everyone who's been
working on the nhs front line for nearly
two years now to deal with this epidemic
uh their uh their hard work their
dedication their sacrifices um uh are
amazing um and we're all in their debt
yep we certainly are um you say we're
guided by the science as far as being
led by the government is concerned one
wonders how much notice we should be
taking of the modeling the latest
modelling that we
saw from the london school of tropical
medicine they were suggesting that worst
case scenario we would see something
like 75 000 deaths from the omicron
variant by the end of april the latest
figures that we had from the 23rd of
december particularly for omicron with
14 deaths as opposed to 75 000. isn't it
time we we stopped going with the worst
case scenario
well i think we need to look at a range
of scenarios um and it's always the case
that we look at uh different academic
models models by their very definition
are not predictions um they just run
through what is likely to happen and
again at different stages in this
pandemic sorry to interrupt but likely
to happen 14 deaths as opposed to 75 000
come on
sorry once again i'm afraid i heard your
producer or or one of the excellent
technical team in sky just speaking in
my ear there so i i missed your question
i do apologize
not at all i'm sorry about that i was
saying there's a big difference between
14 deaths and 75 000. some people would
say that potentially was scare-mongering
no i don't think it's scaremongering at
all and no one is setting out to
scaremonger what we are always setting
out to do is to ensure that we are in a
position to model a range of scenarios
and to be ready for um
those different outcomes i think it
would be a mistake not to model some
scenarios where the nhs is under very
severe pressure so that we can make sure
that the resources are there i think it
would be irresponsible not to have a
range of scenarios because we need to be
in a position where we can cope with uh
uh however the virus mutates however the
epidemic develops um and that's why it
is right that we have these scenarios
but it's also the case and and you're
right here as well that we stress that
these are models they are not
predictions
um
how long will lateral flow tests be free
as long as we need them
and how long do you think that might be
again one of the things about the
pandemic is that it's been impossible to
predict with certainty throughout but it
is the case that in this country lateral
flow tests are free and unlike in in
many other jurisdictions they're a vital
tool in making sure that we can curb the
spread of the infection and also that
people who need to isolate do so but as
as you pointed out right at the very
beginning of our conversation we are
moving to a situation we're not there
yet but we are moving to a situation
where it is possible to say that we can
live with covid and that the pressure on
the nhs and on vital public services is
abating but
it's absolutely vital to recognize that
we are not there yet and as the health
secretary has reminded us there will be
some difficult weeks ahead and that is
why we all need to continue to test
continue if we are positive to isolate
and continue broadly to support the nhs
as it goes through a challenging period
but one in which the frontline
professionals are doing an amazing job
so we are considering phasing out
lateral flow tests but not for the
coming weeks as we continue to try to
deal with the omicron variant and indeed
the delta variant that is still around
over the next few weeks so not for the
next few weeks in other words is that
right
as the prime minister and others have
said we will do whatever it takes
talk to me about why you're here today
which is um cladding
uh four billion pounds um to help those
people that are basically
stuck
in homes that are unsafe or they can't
sell them
is it going to be a voluntary scheme for
these developers to get involved
well we want to say to developers and
indeed to all those who have a a role to
play in recognizing their responsibility
that we want to work with them um but if
it's the case that uh it's necessary to
do so then we will use legal means um
and ultimately if necessary the tax
system in order to ensure that uh those
who have deep pockets those who are
responsible for the upkeep of these
buildings pay rather than the
leaseholders the individuals who are
in the past were being asked uh to pay
with money they didn't have for a
problem that they did not cause
so you're saying that there could be a
developer's tax and you would bring in
the full weight of the law to make sure
that they cough up
yes and i think it's important to look
to this in a balanced way there are some
developers um some people in the
property business uh who have been
stepping up to the plate already living
up to their responsibilities removing
dangerous cladding making sure that
buildings are safe i applaud that work
but there are others who still have more
to do and it's a straightforward
question should it be those with uh the
big bucks the big profits um uh who have
been responsible for the construction of
these buildings and who are the ultimate
owners of these buildings or should it
be individuals uh who have worked hard
in order to get a mortgage and who are
now being saddled with costs for faults
that were not their responsibility
if you put the question like that then i
think there can only be one answer
what about people in buildings that have
got the challenges with problems other
than cladding insulation wooden
balconies etc etc the dclg committee
estimated sorting out fire defects could
cost something like 15 billion pounds
are you going to be looking at that as
well
we are i'm i i think the thing about the
costs there is that we've just been
talking about modeling and estimates and
so on i don't think the costs would be
anything like that but i do think it is
necessary to make sure that um the
buildings are safe i think it's also
important to bear in mind though um that
um the uh overall majority of buildings
which are not high-rise buildings are
safe
and
it's important that we get a proper
sense of proportion that we make sure
firstly that we get rid of dangerous
cladding that we make those buildings
which are currently unsafe totally safe
but at the same time uh with other
buildings that uh uh
uh have been considered uh to be in
scope of particular types of work it's
important that we also get a sense of
proportion back because one of the
problems that uh that many people living
in flats face is that at the moment
there is a question mark hanging over
the safety of their flats that means
they can't get a mortgage um or others
who want to buy the fat count get a
mortgage and they can't move on and what
we want to do is to tackle
the real dangers and restore a sense of
proportion
and in addition to that they're
struggling to pay their energy bills um
should we be cutting vat
on energy bills
well again i think it's important that
we look at a range of options here in
order to to help um and the government
already provides additional support for
those who
are in
particular difficulties
we have warm homes payments there are
other ways in which we support people so
i think it's important when we're
thinking about how we help people that
we look at ways in which we can target
our support most effectively on those
most in need
is that a yes or no to cutting that on
bills as far as you're concerned
well i think we should always seek to
cut taxes whenever we can but also it's
important when we are providing support
for people though we also target it most
on those who need it most
so cutting that on energy bills is
something that you would support
well i i you know in my view
the more we can cut taxes the better but
at this point i think that the
the prudent and the responsible thing to
do is to recognize um that we need to
take a balanced approach and a balanced
approach means that when we can support
we provide support most to those in the
most difficult circumstances
so particularly on energy bills at the
moment given that some people could find
themselves uh with a bill going up more
than 600 quid
well i think that's precisely why we
should be concentrating our support most
on uh those with the uh uh
the least income um uh the least where
with all uh in order to be able to um
meet those and other bills and that's
what we do we target support uh whether
it is through uh warm homes payments or
through uh other interventions on those
who are most in need and i think uh most
people would recognize that if we do
have uh ultimately sold taxpayers money
if we do have taxpayers money uh to be
able to provide people with support then
it should be directed towards those who
are in the toughest circumstances
talk to me about the parties that um
seem to keep going on at uh number 10 um
downing street it looks as though there
were more taking place on the 20th of of
may last year were you invited
um uh i can't remember what i was doing
on the 20th of may last year uh okay
number 10 did you go to last year no no
no no
no uh very very few km
two things that i would say
uh no uh i think it's important to
stress that
all of these matters are being
investigated by sugree
a brilliant civil servant someone who
will investigate without fear or favor
sue is a permanent secretary in the
department where i'm a minister i don't
think it would be problem for me to say
anything other than uh everyone knows
that she is a person of great integrity
someone who will investigate this
remorselessly and whose conclusions we
should wait for and until we get those
conclusions
i shouldn't attempt to preempt it and
nor should anyone else okay let me just
ask you one final question before i let
you go more than a million people have
now signed a position petition i should
say saying that they don't want tony
blair to receive a knighthood why are
they all wrong
well i i don't want to get into an
argument with a million people now okay
but one of the things that i would say
is that while uh tony blair
is a prime minister whose record
as any prime minister who was in power
for ten years uh will it has a record
which divides i think we should all
recognize that he served this country he
continues to serve this country uh and
uh uh i don't think it's possible for
anyone to be in a position like that
without attracting controversy
um and without um inviting opposition
but um uh for myself if i look back at
uh tony blair's record uh while there
are aspects of it with which i can
disagree i think any fair-minded person
would say that he was an outstanding
statesman and reformer um and as a prime
minister who uh put public service first
uh this recognition from her majesty is
entirely appropriate
which particular aspects did you
disagree with
um well we could be here for another um
hour or so if we ran through all of the
things which teddy bear did with which i
disagreed on those things which he did
which um i think were worthwhile um i
think
it's more important to accentuate the
positive in anyone's record and so i
would say that the establishment of
academy schools and more choice in
education was a good thing um i think it
was also the case that the approach he
took on being
determined to crack down on crime and
anti-social behavior even if it wasn't
always delivered effectively was right
and i also think that uh uh his
recognition of the importance of a
country like the united kingdom being on
the side of liberty internationally was
also writing okay i'm sorry about the
technical uh challenges i do apologize
for that one way of getting around that
of course is for you to come into the
studio next time so i look forward to
seeing you very soon thank you
not not at all okay it's always a
pleasure i look forward to seeing you
soon and can i say what a uh a kind
thoughtful and gentle voice producer you
have um i'm only sorry that he cut
across our conversation
yes you can and i'll pass it on thank
you very much indeed thanks a lot
looking at some of this morning's front
pages for you now start with the mail
pleading with the prime minister to save
us from a cost of living crisis the
murrah has an investigation into the
tory levelling up agenda they report
from a crumbling school in yorkshire
that can't afford repairs it says and on
the front of the times nhs leaders say
that optimistic further coveted
restrictions can be avoided as most
hospitals are managing to get through
the omicron wave
still to come on the programme for you
this morning with fuel bills set to rise
we'll speak to labour's jonathan
reynolds about their plans to help firms
hit by the energy crisis
after more than one million people sign
a petition calling for sir tony blem to
have his knighthood removed and speak to
his former director of political
operations as well as a father whose son
was killed in iraq to get their take on
the former prime minister
and victory for novak djokovic we'll
talk more about the star's win in
melbourne this morning with former
tennis player roger taylor
tragic news coming out of new york today
a faulty electric heater believed to be
the source of a fire that killed at
least 19 people at an apartment building
in new york including nine children it's
the city's deadliest fire for 30 years
ius correspondent greg milan reports
flames pour from an apartment in the
twin parks complex pictures shared on
the citizen app revealing the first
moments of what's become one of the
deadliest residential fires in modern
american history
in the three minutes it took fire crews
to reach the building they said the
smoke had reached every floor
they found victims on each one survivors
among them people who knew children who
died described the horror and the
helplessness tomorrow is a school day
they're going to ask me where they are
friends
they're going to ask me tomorrow where
they are friends because then go
together then come back together what
i'm going to tell them tomorrow
the windows were blown out either by the
heat of the fire or residents desperate
for air smashing them it was a horrific
scene because you have to realize
besides being a firefighter you have to
deal with the mental stress of seeing
this carnage of what happened in the
bronx today within hours investigators
had pinpointed the cause this fire began
in an apartment that spans two floors on
the second and third floor of the
building
it started in a malfunctioning electric
space heater
and because doors to that apartment and
a stairwell had been left open the fire
spread quickly with no external fire
escape the only way out was those
stairwells filled with smoke
we are indeed a city in shock
it's impossible to go into that room
where scorers of family
who are in such grief who are in pain
to see it in a mother's eyes as i held
her
who lost her entire family
it all happened days after 12 people
including eight children were killed in
a fire in a house in philadelphia it's
thought smoke detectors there weren't
working
at the twin parks one resident said he'd
ignored the smoke alarm at first because
there have been so many false alarms
recently he soon realized like so many
that this one was horribly real greg
milam sky news
my mom's deposed leader aung sang
is to serve four more years in prison
after being found guilty of illegally
importing and possessing walkie-talkies
and violating coronavirus restrictions
let's get more on that should we and
speak to our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins uh
standing by in bangkok hello to suburban
tell us more
morning kay well as you say another four
years in prison for ansu qi this time
for illegally importing and possessing
walkie-talkies and breaking covert 19
rules and of course this is on top of
the two-year prison sentence that she
was handed in december that was
initially a four-year sentence before it
was cut in half by the junta leader but
often we have this focus on ansan tsuchi
but it's an important moment to really
reflect and remind people about the
wider situation the problems facing
people living in myanmar
we have seen widespread violence since
the military took power in a coup in
february we've seen shelling of
civilians many civilians running from
their homes either to avoid shelling or
to avoid intense fighting which has
broken out between gentle forces and
guerrilla forces also more than 11 000
people detained by junta forces since
the coup more than 1400 killed by gender
forces so today the focus on ansang su
chi but the problems facing people in
myanmar as a whole continue
okay thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you on the program now the
american stand-up comedian bob segat has
died
at the age of just 65. he was best known
for his tv roles as danny tanner in full
house and as the narrator in how i met
your mother the circumstances of his
death are still unclear but it's not
being treated as suspicious
buckingham palace has unveiled the
programme of events to mark the queen's
platinum jubilee celebrations will
include the queen opening her private
estates to the public some of the
world's biggest stars performing outside
buckingham palace and a four-day bank
holiday weekend in early june
not clear though which event the queen
will attend
now take a look at this incredible bit
of video from la here we
go it may be the home of hollywood but
this is a real life amazing escape
police saved a pilot who made an
emergency landing on a railroad track
there you go they pulled him clear just
before wait for it they're
train smashed into the light aircraft
my goodness me
now more than 160 people have been
killed and almost 8 000 people have been
detaining kazakhstan following violent
anti-government protests in the last
week let's take a look at how the
country got to this point since its
independence in 1991 kazakhstan's
economy has grown rapidly due to vast
reserves of oil gas and uranium the
country also provides road and rail
links between china and western europe
protests began last sunday in western
kazakhstan over a sharp rise in fuel
prices and spread right across the
country many are unhappy about
widespread inequality and financial
hardship security forces used tear gas
and stun grenades to try to disperse
crowds but protesters took control of
buildings like the mayor's office and
the airport in almaty the country's
largest city
order has now been restored with both
russian and belarusian troops on the
ground a total of 164 people died
including a four-year-old girl
diana magna reports
the russian troops keep on pouring in
there are armenians belarusians tajiks
and kurdish too but it is mostly
russians
al-marti airport is heavily guarded
their mandate to protect key
infrastructure
it means we still can't fly in to where
the most violent of last week's protests
happened where the shoot to kill order
is definitely still active
but international flights are now open
to the kazakh capital an 18-hour car
ride further north
no sultan didn't see any of almaty's
upheaval a protest early on and
checkpoints now outside the city but
life goes on as normal even if the whole
country is now under a state of
emergency this city has undergone a few
name changes in its latest incarnation
as north sultan is in honor of no sultan
nazarbayev who is still technically what
the kazakhstan
leader of the nation but the question is
for how much longer
nazarbayev was the longest of central
asia's post-soviet strongman till he
handed power to his hand-picked
successor kasim jomat takayev in 2019.
rumors now arrive as to power struggles
among the elites that takayev was forced
to call on russia's help to fend off a
power grab
[Applause]
questions circulate who were these men
who turned the protests so violent why
were security services strangely absent
when shops and the airport were
ransacked
was the people's protest hijacked by
other forces and why hasn't nazarbayev
shown himself
one of the very few opposition voices in
kazakhstani
yes i think so
his time is over
it was supposed to have finished much
earlier but unfortunately it was a long
process and i think most of the problems
in kazakhstan are because of this
takayev now has a chance to prove
himself outside nazarbayev's shadow to
see if he responds to his people's
frustrations
or if he defaults to switching one
autocracy for another
dinah magnay sky news north sultan
kazakhstan
well our international affairs editor
dominic waghorn is in geneva for us this
morning but first to our security and
defense editor deborah haynes who is
standing by in kiev good morning to you
both we're going to talk uh ukraine uh
shortly not sure i've got a bit of a
problem with my lighting here so we'll
cut to you um instead deborah let's
start with you um should we talk to me
um about what we can expect over the
next few days with russia and ukraine
so this meeting that's taking place in
geneva is obviously all about security
here in europe in ukraine but also wider
security in europe british and american
officials have raised the alarm about
the possibility of a further russian
invasion of ukraine but here in this
country they want people to remember
that russia invaded ukraine already it
annexed crimea it's backed a separatist
insurgency in the east and they have a
big message to western leaders not to
make any compromises with vladimir putin
that could further undermine their
security and with so much at stake it's
hardly surprising that a ukrainian
minister said to me last month that
should there be another invasion of
ukraine it could be the spark that
ignites much wider conflict in europe
potentially even world war iii
um and dominic talks continuing in uh
geneva of course uh from today with both
the us um and the russians the russians
feeling very aggrieved they feel that
nato is continuing to encroach on its
territory
yeah okay and they they're sounding
quite ominous really uh sergey ryankov
the russian deputy foreign minister and
his american counterpart wendy sherman
had dinner last night ahead of the talks
beginning in earnest in the building
behind me today and uh coffee was
sounding a bit more optimistic after
those talks but earlier in the day he
said he was so unimpressed by what the
americans have been saying that he
doesn't see these talks possibly lasting
much more than today they're due to go
on to wednesday and thursday in
different european capitals with nato
and the rce of course i think there is a
huge gulf still between the russians and
the americans vladimir putin wants uh
the immediate unconditional acceptance
of his demands for security guarantees
particularly his demand that ukraine can
never join nato the americans have said
that's a non-starter they are prepared
to talk about other things like reducing
alliance activity in european eastern
european nations and missile deployment
in ukraine and that i think is the focus
the americans want to see
begin on these talks today but there is
that huge gulf between them the fear i
think is that the russians will use
these talks as an excuse they'll find a
pretext to invade ukraine and the gun
that's being held to the
head of the ukrainians as the u.s
secretary of state put it yesterday is
the fact that you have over a hundred
thousand russian troops camped on uh
russia's borders with ukraine so it's a
question of using these talks today and
in wednesday and on thursday for the
western diplomats to try and look the
russians in the eye and say if that's
what you are planning you need to think
again the cost will be too severe if you
do so okay thank you both for now and
just to flag that we've got ukraine's
ambassador to the uk joining us live in
the studio to discuss those talks in
geneva at half past eight
uh western drama the power of the dog
and the remake of west side story were
among the big winners at this year's
golden globes after a controversial year
when organizers were criticized for
their lack of diversity the ceremony
wasn't broadcast on tv and went ahead
without a red carpet or a celebrity
audience and many of the winners have
yet to acknowledge the awards despite
this the president of the awards told
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer she was hopeful for the
future
we're all we're very optimistic we're
very proud of the changes over the last
nine months and and you know we're
hopeful for the future for the golden
globes and
and you know coming monday i think we're
all really focusing on on our ongoing
reforms because this is obviously not
you know a goal that that that we have
achieved it's a journey that we're on
well the housing secretary michael gove
has told sky news this morning that the
country is moving to a situation where
it's possible to live with kovid but he
added we're not quite there yet it comes
after reports of the weekend suggested
plans are being made to put an end to
free lateral flow tests i asked mr gove
if that was the case
we are moving to a situation we're not
there yet but we are moving to a
situation where it is possible to say
that we can live with covid and that the
pressure on the nhs and on vital public
services is abating but
it's absolutely vital to recognize that
we are not there yet and as the health
secretary has reminded us there will be
some difficult weeks ahead and that is
why we all need to continue to test
continue if we are positive to isolate
and continue broadly to support the nhs
as it goes through a challenging period
lots to get our teeth into with
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock tomorrow
with us now good morning what did you
make what do you have to say morning
kate yes we are leading to a point where
the government are going to have to make
some kind of announcement on how we live
with covid in the longer term michael
gove was keen to say that while there
has been encouraging news so far on
hospitalizations we have to be careful
because the peak has not been reached
everywhere in the country but he said
we'll have lateral flow tests for as
long as we need them didn't put a time
scale on it and in many other countries
people pay for them and the government
there was a story floated at the weekend
that we that may happen here too so that
is one to watch he didn't give his
backing to cutting the self-isolation
period to five days though interestingly
after nadim zahawi his cabinet colleague
did do that so that's clearly still
being intensely discussed in government
and a quick thought on cladding yes big
package being announced today on
cladding the government have been very
keen to do something about this issue
affecting so many people they want to
raise four billion pounds michael gove
said if the developers don't cough up
the money they do face a developer's tax
we'll get more details of that in
parliament this afternoon but i think a
lot of campaigners will be eagerly
looking at the detail okay more on that
at nine o'clock of course tomorrow night
thanks very much indeed yeah talking
about that weren't we with the housing
secretary who said that he does favor a
developer's tax our correspondent shingi
maruriki is in west london for us this
morning and uh that will be some solace
i'm guessing for the people of granville
morning cake that's right i think this
new policy which michael gove is calling
a reset means that leaseholders will no
longer have to pay those those low
interest loans which they would have had
to pay to replace the flammable cladding
that coated grenfell tower and hundreds
of other buildings across the country
and michael gove with pretty stern words
both on your program and in the
government statement saying that he
wants the property developers to sign up
to the plan by the end of march but some
campaigners say that this doesn't go far
enough because it applies to just
cladding when there are other pl plenty
of other fire safety defects as well
involved in some of these buildings from
from fire compartmentation issues to
fire doors and other issues like wooden
balconies and also the scheme doesn't
apply to buildings which are under 11 11
meters applies to buildings to 11 which
are 11 to 18 meters so even if this is a
step i think that there are still plenty
of questions to answer in this building
crisis
okay for now thanks very much thank you
new year's honest list is often a source
of controversy and this year was no
exception more than one million people
have already signed a petition calling
for sir tony blair to have his
knighthood removed earlier i also asked
michael gove about that
i think we should all recognize that he
served this country he continues to
serve this country
and uh i don't think it's possible for
anyone to be in a position like that
without attracting controversy um um and
without um inviting opposition but um uh
for myself if i look back at uh tony
blair's record uh while there are
aspects of it with which i can disagree
i think any fair-minded person would say
that he was an outstanding statesman and
performer
and as a prime minister who uh put
public service first
this recognition from her majesty is
entirely appropriate
we're joined now by uh john mcternan who
worked as a tony blair's director of
political operations while he served as
uh prime minister it's good to talk to
you this morning thanks so much indeed
for joining us um so we've heard there
why tony blair should uh get his
knighthood um whether he deserves it or
not given that he was the people's prime
minister and so many of them are saying
he doesn't deserve it should he say
actually i'm not going to take it
i think tony never claimed to be the
people's prime minister he actually uh
said that diana was the people's
princess um
to make the point of course i know tony
tony's always said
uh
it was the greatest of privileges to be
the prime minister of the uk for two
reasons one
we're the greatest country in the world
and and i totally agree with that i'm
sure michael goes would um and secondly
everybody is free to have and express
their opinions about him uh what he did
as a prime minister uh how he acted and
he celebrates the fact that there's
criticism of him he doesn't welcome uh
people disagreeing with them but he
knows that's part of democracy so that a
million people disagree with him he's no
surprise um
nine ten million people always voiced
against him in general elections uh even
when he won landslides uh that's the
nature of our country uh there's there's
more than a million people who disagree
uh with almost every prime minister
we've ever had so i think you have to go
back to the core case as michael gove
did and you know if you settle as as uh
tony did a dispute in northern ireland
which hadn't simply lasted since the
troubles restarted sun hadn't simply
started
been going since the 1920s when
partition happened been going for you
know seven or eight hundred centuries
there was a dispute about ireland and we
have settled peace in northern ireland
because of tony blair only he could have
finished it many people were involved
but there is no doubt by everybody who
was involved in that that without tony
blair uh the peace deal wouldn't have
happened and imagine our country now uh
with the troubles still continuing so
for that one thing for that one thing
alone i am i i think the queen was right
to give him the order of the garter
of those more than 100 more than one
million people some of them feel so
strongly that they want to return the
elizabeth crosses that have been um
awarded to their children posthumously
and
wives and husbands of those that were
killed in iraq so the blood of their
kids and their families um they're
saying we don't want these awards
because he's going to get this and
as a result one has to think
really really is that totally
appropriate that he should be getting
his knighthood when people feel so
strongly about what happened
many many people uh
have suffered terrible losses uh in the
iraq war in the afghanistan war i lost a
close colleague and close friend uh who
was
a colleague in the ministry of defense
and who was also a
uh those losses are deep and those
losses can never
ever be recovered from in a sense they
become part part of your life you're
suffering in your grief
and the loss goes on
um the reality about the afghanistan war
uh when
my friend died
is that that war was a treaty obligation
for the united kingdom uh once an attack
was launched on the united states the
911 attack the united states invoked the
nato treaty uh and we had to go to us to
to to to remove the capacity for al
qaeda to have a whole country from which
it operated and could operate terrorism
against the whole of uh the whole of
europe uh the whole of the world to any
any any place they wanted to go to and
the afghan the the iraq war which people
do have very strong views about and i
respect them tony respects them the iraq
war in the end uh only one man is
responsible for the iraq war
and that is saddam hussein um a fascist
dictator who
refused uh to
acknowledge the power of an ultimatum of
the united nations ignored it wouldn't
allow weapon inspectors in
and gave the world the whole world order
a choice
do you allow a dictator just to go well
i don't agree i'm not going to let the
united nations uh weapon inspectors and
i'm just going to ignore uh the the
attempt to to uh to having you know
peace monitor to have uh treaties
monitored i'm going to ignore all that
do you just go fair enough or walk away
or do you have to do something we face
the same choice now with putin in
ukraine um and these are very very
difficult choices we have our armed
forces and we respect the work that they
do and we respect the people who serve
and those who lose and the families we
have our armed forces because we want to
keep the peace we have to prepare
for war and at times because of
individuals like saddam hussein because
of organizations like al-qaeda uh prime
ministers make the most difficult choice
they ever have to make uh they have to
make the choice whether to go to war or
not
okay
we must leave it there thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
programme this morning we're joined now
by peter um really whose son lance
corporal sean really tragically died in
iraq in
2003 you had the opportunity didn't you
to meet tony blair you chose not to
shake his hand why was that
the soldiers and the other blood of the
iraqi people
it wasn't
some of the things that's just been said
the the ireland agreement yeah that's
fair enough they just settled they
settled the disputing island but we are
still getting uh
old age pensioners
being technically cut to the court but
it's likely what a one-sided agreement
um i know
that sean tragically died i think i'm
writing saying in in 2003 he was in a a
vehicle
which basically wasn't fit for purpose
was was the argument a land rover crash
it was blamed
on poor equipment i'm sure that you uh
treasure
all of the medals that you were you have
uh received and of course the medals he
received while he was alive are you also
contemplating returning his elizabeth
cross
no i'm not because it that that would
that's
that was something safe
to what we what we're doing now
that would be memory issue
and i will be giving that
good i'm i'm i'm pleased to hear that
tell me
what justice though you would like to
see
for sean uh what would you see
um as as
what happened to him and and in any way
trying to justify that it's not the
natural order of things for your child
to die before you and even 20 years on
it's you know i'm sure impossibly
difficult to talk about it but is there
anything that can be done
there's absolutely nothing that can be
done uh
as far as as far as like as far as i'm
concerned
tony blair is an uncomfortable walking
you know
the things that he's been taught
gentlemen before talking about went to
humanity the united nations coffin and
said that the the invasion would be
illegal without an another
uh
another ruling
so the world was illegal but
gone on
this issue that he took sorry
while while he was prime minister
he can't be prosecuted for that but that
does not that doesn't mean that he's not
guilty of what we do so ideally it would
be
for me but charlie blair
not only has done it but he's brought
the country to distribute and he still
does occasionally he still says because
the great british is a joke no the the
million signatures on the petition
obviously it's another whole country
where they talk about having to get rid
of al-qaeda
and but they're vacuumed that they're
left in isis
so
terrorism around the world caused by
isis partly partly it's tony blair's
responsibility because he
he
played parliament
the main the big the first thing that i
would have charged mr public office
because he did
mislead parliament
when
sorry
no no i'm just going to say
unfortunately we were out of time i'm
obviously listening to every word that
you say and and i would like to talk to
you in more detail going forward so we
will chat to you again but thanks for
taking the time to join us this morning
thank you
thank you
talking there about uh whether tony
blair deserves his knighthood the
arguments for
and against you've probably got a view
on that haven't you can tweet me
directly if you would like to at k
burley
meantime the world health organization
has said that the omicron variant of
coronavirus that's causing the current
wave of infections may be less severe
than delta but warned it's not
mild joined now by the world health
organization's special envoy for curving
19 regular contributor to the program of
course dr nabarro hello to you thanks
for joining us on the programme this
morning happy new year um happy new year
are we finally on top of this
uh well i'm afraid we are
moving through the marathon but there's
no actual way to say that we're at the
end we can see the end in sight
but we're not there and there's
going to be some bumps before we get
there and i can't tell you how bad
they're going to be
but i can at least tell you what i'm
expecting
um do we need more well tell me what you
are expecting
uh first of all
this virus is continuing to evolve we
have omicron but we'll get more variants
secondly it really is affecting the
whole world and whilst uh health
services in western europe are just
about coping in many other parts of the
world they are completely overwhelmed
and and thirdly uh it's it's really
clear
that there's no scope for major
restrictions in any country particularly
poor countries people have just got to
keep working and so there are some very
tough choices for politicians right now
it's going to be very as i say difficult
the next three months at least please um
how are you feeling about
um us giving donations of astrazeneca
vaccines to those third world countries
looking at the figures um it drops very
quickly doesn't it after 20 weeks to
less than half um half
efficacy and even more steeply for the
over 65s
yeah the there are lots of questions
okay still about
what does determine vaccine efficacy
if i want to know whether a vaccine is
working the most important thing i need
to find out is whether it stops people
from getting severely ill and dying
measuring levels of antibodies in the
blood is what we call a proxy it gives
us a rough estimate of what's going on
but it's not the whole story
and i think uh astrozenica vaccine shows
that it's got a lot of utility uh in
helping to prevent people from having
severe disease and it should be used and
it should also be
made available more widely there's one
great advantage to that vaccine which is
that it can be kept uh at really uh um
normal fridge temperature so
everybody should be really proud of the
fact that this vaccine
not only is useful and should be
encouraging continued sharing of it
okay um there's a university professor
here in the united kingdom um referred
to as a um a member of independent stage
professor christina pagle saying that
we're doomed to massive surges two or
three times a year
do you yes
i heard about that one by the way i do
follow her social media very carefully
uh i defined the assessments helpful
and
it's right you know the way this virus
is behaving and has behaved really since
we first met it is that it builds up and
then surges quite dramatically and then
it comes down again and then it surges
again about every three or four months
now it's it's difficult to use past
behavior to predict the future
and i don't like doing that too much but
i would agree that the pattern i think
that is going to happen with this virus
is continued surges and living with
covid means being able to prepare for
these surges and to react to them really
quickly when they occur life can go on
we can get the economy going again in
many countries but we just have to be
really respectful of the virus
and that means having really good plans
in place for dealing with the surges
okay well i hope that that means that
you'll be able to see much more of your
grandchildren uh in the year ahead it's
good to talk to you thank you very much
i've had some emotional therapy thank
you i want to keep it going
absolutely it's good to talk to you
doctor thank
you now here's a good one you've
probably heard of why the chicken
crossed the road but how about a
different kind of flightless bird here
we are
yep chinese city of zhang ji 80
ostriches decided to make a break for it
when the gate to the farm they were
being held in was left open
naughty farmer someone's in trouble
the owner managed to capture
all of them
no small feat when you consider they do
a top speed of 70 miles an hour they're
now back safely in their pen and there
are no injuries to report so no harm
no foul
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
wick ahead starting off cloudy with some
rain but the weather will settle down as
high pressure builds bringing overnight
frost and fog it's been freezing hasn't
it all weekend most places will have a
grey and damp start this morning with
fog patches in the east and outbreaks of
rain in the west it's going to be windy
over northern scotland with some hill
snow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
just want to bring you some of the
softer stories making headlines in the
papers this morning before i let you go
that is amazing you don't see that every
day in the animal kingdom the lion or
she's lioness in fact forced to turn
back and run away after being turned on
by a buffalo in africa lone buffaloes
males always always grumpy they're
called duggar boys and if the lioness is
on her own she's got absolutely no
chance
against him captured by wildlife
photographers in kenya the buffalo was
protecting its young
so there you go and don't come back
either
slightly closer to home in the mirror
where these beautiful shots of the
aurora borealis or northern lights were
taken on fine horn beach in mori in the
scottish highlands how amazing is that
have you ever seen the northern lights
if you have actually sent me some
pictures if you wouldn't mind please on
twitter at k burley and we will use them
during the program how amazing is that
the phenomenon is only visible in the uk
during the darkest nights of winter and
from one natural phenomenon to another
in the telegraph this oh i don't know
how to pronounce this it's an
ichthyosaur skeleton it's been unveiled
by paleontologists
in the midlands i know how to say that
because of ross of course in friends the
dinosaur was one of the giants of the
deep when it roamed earth seas
180 million years ago scientists have
called it one of the greatest finds
in british history it looks like a very
big crocodile doesn't it
there you go it's hundreds of millions
of years old and just up there that's
how it probably would have looked when
it was alive uh coming up in just a few
moments time the very latest from what
the housing sector michael gove told us
uh just a short time ago he says we're
going to have to learn with covid and
we're moving in that direction he said
we're not there yet he didn't tell us
how long we would be having
a free lateral flow test for also talked
about tax
for developers all that to come in just
[Music]
you